>> As you guys know, this is Dale Dougherty
who is co-founder of O'Reilly Media and founder
of Make Magazine and the Maker Faire so if
you could just give a round of applause.
[applause]
Dale Dougherty: Good. I have to stay near
the podium I gather. How many of you are familiar
with Make and Maker Faire? Good. That's probably
why you're here. You know, today I tried to
put some context around what I see in what
we're doing and also show you a lot of things
that are coming up in Make and talking a bit
about Maker Faire and I'm going to start with
a fairly gratuitous video but it actually
shows a festival in Mexico. It has nothing
to do with Make or Maker Faire and I don't
think I could do what they're doing at Maker
Faire without getting a huge amount of trouble
and to be said, you probably shouldn't do
this at home either. It's called Sledgehammer
Fireworks. [video playing in background] And
they tape explosive to an end of a sledgehammer
and then hit it on an I-Beam. [video continues
to play in background] It's very much a DIY,
get involved, do it yourself thing and what's
kind of interesting in this video is a fella
comes up
related to the person shooting the video and
starts asking questions and they say, "Hey,
do you want to try
it?" So let's go from there. [fireworks in
background from video] Is it possible to turn
the lights off over
here? [video continues to play in background]
Watch how quickly this guy comes up behind
him. At any rate, so it's not something you
want to do I think but it's kind of interesting,
not only the activity as a group
of people doing something but they dress the
part and do that which kind of leads me into
my idea here that
I wanted to talk about. Do you know there's
84,000 people registered on the US Census
who list a primary
occupation as Elvis impersonator? You know,
there's something about - well, I'm calling
it the rise of
tribute bands. Amateurs acting like pros,
doing things that are like what someone else
does but doing it at
their own level, you know? And to some degree
to be able to take an idea, make it your own,
and perform it
in front of people. Here's a five year old
kid who dressed up like the drummer from KISS
and you know
creates a YouTube video [video playing in
background] and you know you probably wouldn't
watch him if he
wasn't dressed up like Eric Singer. [video
continues to play in background] What is it
that's going on here?
You know, to some degree there are musicians,
there are bands out there but as in this quote
here he said,
"You know, let's be Guns and Roses for Halloween."
They went out and said I get to play someone
and be that person that I really admire but
they somehow got a crowd and it mattered to
them that they got a group of people in front
of them. This is another tribute band, DSO,
Dark Star Orchestra. They actually recreate
Grateful Dead concerts. They take a particular
concert on a particular date and they play
every song that
was played by the Grateful Dead on that date.
They sell CDs and they sell everything. I
mean, they've become their own touring band
and this is my [inaudible] Led Zeppelin tribute
band and you know a reporter asked him, "Do
you think the rise in the number of tribute
bands means that's something missing from
today's music?" And he says, "Yes, you know.
It's too corporate. Creativity is gone." I
mean, you're basically copying someone and
saying that creativity is gone but one of
the patterns that I'd like to talk about is
in many ways that when you make something,
it doesn't have to be your own idea. It doesn't
have to be original. Copying is a particular
human thing that we do well and it's a pretty
good starting point for many of us and it
often
leads to other things. I mean you could argue
that Guitar Hero makes everyone into a tribute
band and you
play in your living room. We came across this
group, Guitar Zeros, who take Guitar Heroes
and began playing real music with their play
guitars. They took the plastic guitar controllers
and realized it had sensors and you could
do different movements with it and then they
plugged it up to their own controller and
began to
create their own music, create their own band
and we put them on the cover of Make last
year sometime so
it's a pattern. These are enthusiasts. They
are doing something they love, their amateurs.
That's kind of
the root word, root meaning of the word amateur
but I think what's often lost in this is that
their actually
really interested in creating a following.
They want to connect to other people. This
is something that they
on one hand do on their own but they want
to connect to other people doing similar things
and they want to
share that with other people, which sort of
leads me to this kind of idea about what can
we learn from
garage bands, what can we learn from that
process meaning; and I'm thinking in terms
of education. I'm
thinking in terms of innovation so it's a
kind of pattern. A garage band, you don't
necessarily need formal
training in music say to play in a garage
band. It might help but it's not required.
What's almost more
important is your own initiative, that you
start something yourself and you're committed
to working at it
and then pretty soon you begin to find other
people who are at your own level of ability
or interest and you
try to meet with them and you try to get together
and do things. Something that I'm seeing kind
of broadly
in this area, and not just garage bands, but
you think about it; today in many, many different
areas,
amateurs and professionals are using the same
tools. In this case, it's guitars. In the
case of publishing,
I'm probably using the same tools that my
audience is using. We are all kind of converging
on the same tool
set but behind it you practice and you play
and that's kind of the pattern of making for
most people. You
are practicing something to get better at
it but you're also playing, you're enjoying
it and as I said earlier, you realize that
at some point it's okay to copy. We probably
call it sharing in a more fashionable sense
but we inherently copy each other just as
when you watch that Sledgehammer Fireworks
you start thinking about, "Well, really? How
could I do that?" But also you begin to create
a following and you're interested in that
and I think that's again what we're beginning
to see in Makers. What's really different
today say from the models of a lone tinkerer
is that they, it's easier for them to connect
with other people. You are often dependent
on the people in your neighborhood, the people
in your school to find sort of fellow travelers.
Today, I think you can reach out and connect
to lots of different groups but in the garage
band model, you're looking for venues. Where
can we go to play together? Where can we get
friends to come and see us? And how do you
develop a following over time, and even how
you track that. Well of course, garage bands
go back to even the idea or the paradigm if
you will of garage invention, which is obviously
well known in the Valley here but what you
might not know as well as this is Bagley Avenue.
It's the garage of Henry Ford where in 1896
he built his first vehicle which he called
the Quadricycle. It was really built from
bicycle parts and that's what his garage looked
like then but interestingly enough for Ford,
he had a kind of similar idea. He wasn't the
inventor of automobiles, he was really someone
who was trying to create an affordable, reliable
vehicle that he thought more people could
use. His real interest was to help get people
off of farms and into cities. He grew up on
a farm himself and he thought that was just
a terrible place to have to be all by yourself.
He was also afraid of horses and didn't like
farm work so he wanted to remove some of the
drudgery; but you know there was also this
social component of garages. They were places
to hang out or in the case here of the Homebrew
Computer Club, which is again it's almost
mythical, in terms of the formation of and
start of computing in the Valley but Steve
Wozniak says, "I just love going to the Homebrew
Computer Club and showing off my ideas and
designing neat computers. I was willing to
do that for free for the rest of my life."
And there were things like the West Coast
Computer Fair where early Apple II computers
were shown to people and they had no idea
that other people would be interested in what
they were doing. Well today, maybe the equivalent
of the Homebrew Computer Club is something
called Hackerspaces. This is NYC Resistor
in Brooklyn and it's probably a couple of
years old. There are several in the Bay Area,
Noise Bridge in San Francisco is one hackerspace
and they are kind of a growing movement. These
are a group of individuals who get together
to rent a space, buy equipment, maintain it,
and they pay somewhere between $80 and $100
a month to get together and have a space to
make things in, but like the garage bands
this is sort of the garage bands of the Make
world. This is MakerBot and it's their product
and that's Bre Pettis on your left - well
no, your right. Sorry. And you know they made
this, started it as a business out of NYC
Resistor and you know it's essentially a long
and open source model where there was a project
called RepRap which was trying to do 3D printing
and they took that project and really packaged
it up a nice way. They took the open source
and they used an Arduino controller and they
kind of just created a polished kit that made
it affordable for a new audience of people
to have 3D printers and you know this is kind
of what it looks like sort of being put together.
You know, you have to build the casing and
connect all the electronics together but it's
taking something that, which I'll be talking
about today; it's taking something that costs,
let's say 15 to $20,000, and bringing it down
to a $1,000 or less as a kit model. It kind
is reminiscent of those of you who might remember
laser printers and things of how they started
out very expensive in the almost $30,000 range
and then began finding a broader audience
and came down dramatically in price. So one
aspect is there's a community behind the MakerBot
and they're producing drawings and things
that you can use on the MakerBot to create
objects and so you could go to this site called
Thingiverse, download the graphic, and play
with it, modify it, or just send it right
out to the printer. This is a part and it's
assembled, someone is making a model of a
cathedral, a gothic cathedral and they're
printing out all the individual parts and
then assembling it like that. So, a really
kind of interesting application so that it's
not only the tool but the tool also creates
a community of users who share designs and
expertise. We're not Rolling Stone but these
guys did get on the cover of Make with their
MakerBot in the current issue and we're really
talking a lot about 3D printing and CNC machines
in that. So, kind of relating to the tribute
bands, is sort of, I think, one of the opportunities
in making is this idea of doing knockoffs
and we sometimes say that fairly negatively
and say that China does this knockoff of American
products and things but maybe we need to do
our own knockoffs and we certainly see that
in the DIY world. Again, taking something
that's an industrial 3D printer, looking at
the technology and how with various components
can I make a thousand dollar version of that.
Some of these things are rather fanciful and
different. This is something coming to Maker
Faire called Hermes. Someone built a space
shuttle for themselves. They intend it to
fly someday but right now it's kind of connected
to their garage in Arizona, but again it's
- if you remember, Make is sort of based
on some of the old magazines like Popular
Science and Popular Mechanics and you know
if you go back and look at those old covers,
often it was you know "Build your Own Space
vehicle". In the '50s, it was that sort of
level of fantasy. In fact, they say the most
popular cover is sort of the car that converts
to a plane and every now and then they'll
- it's never been solved in a useful but
everybody believes it's around the corner.
Here's an example of a group called Backyard
Brains. Their PhD graduates from Michigan
in Neuroscience and this a device they call
the SpikerBox and they are trying to measure
the flow of neurons in an insects leg and
all it does is produce a sound of that flow
and they can strike it and do different things
but what was interesting there is these guys
said that it was the third year of grad school
before they got access to the device to hear
this, to plant the electrodes in the insects
leg and listen to it, and that device costs
about $40,000. Well, their SpikerBox is about
a $100 kit and their idea is well suddenly
that device could be out in a high school
biology classroom and you could this experiment
[video playing in background] You can kind
of hear a little bit of it there. It could
be broadened in its use to larger audience.
You know, they said think about what if
telescopes were only available at observatories,
you know? What does it mean to have a telescope
that's
affordable and in your backyard so I think
there's areas of knockoffs like this in scientific
instrumentation and other perhaps industrial
equipment that we might be seeing from Makers.
Either to make something more affordable,
to realize that there are now open components
such as micro controllers that could be used
in making that thing and that a community
can help put it together and finally that
the use could be extended to a broader audience.
This is kind of, in some ways, an idea that's
related to Eric Von Hippel's book in "Democratizing
Innovation" and his idea is that a lot of
product innovation comes from user communities,
not just from a R&D process, which is what
our more conventional model is, and that users
are able to innovate themselves, that they
don't have to develop everything they need.
In fact, being able to
borrow and put together things that other
people have done is pretty much a Makers skill
but I think the
most important point is that users benefit
directly from their own innovations and he
gives a lot of
examples from extreme sports where someone
wants to modify a kayak to go down a certain
kind of rapids and the need a snub nose kayak
and the manufacturers don't make that, they
don't believe there's an audience for that
so someone begins to make that, other people
see him, and you know it's often the start
of a small business. We had a Young Maker
program in San Francisco at the Exploratorium
and one of our young - he's a junior at Mountainview
and he's a professional skateboarder downhill
and he is modifying, he's never had to make
something like this before, but he's modifying
the trucks of his skateboard because he wants
a different kind of feel on such a fast ride
so it's a kind of a similar thing where he's
at the edge of
performance of what standard equipment would
offer and he wants to extend it. These are
all Model T's that
have been modified in the field for different
purposes and you know it sort of tells you
that hacking has
been going on for a long time, that we modify
the things we use. We change them because
we see opportunities to use them in ways that
they're not intended and this is an example
from Monkey Bikes and these are LED wheels
which you know we can put on a bike and you
might use it for just a form of expression
but it also sort of serves as a safety device
as well, but again modifying something fairly
simple so in many ways what I see in the Make
Spaces and from the beginning is people are
playing with technology the way we play with
music or we play in other areas, and out of
that sparks new ideas and sparks sort of new
opportunities to meet other people. Communities
organize around projects and tools and skill
sets. I mentioned Arduino and it's becoming
this really important thing that a lot of
people are learning electronics to be able
to create specialized devices. I was meeting
with someone yesterday who's at Stanford working
on an artificial knee, the JaipurKnee, and
you know they are really fascinated by what
cheap micro controllers can allow them to
do in areas that they might not have had and
again part of the design going on with something
like JaipurKnee was to make it affordable
in a very different market. We also have artists
collaborating and creating new forms of expression.
This is a pulse jet organ which not only makes
terrific sound but it shoots flame in the
air and I just like the idea of the keyboard
there connected to something that complicated.
What's pretty cool too is it also folds up
into a little car and like something from
Star Wars rolls away after a performance.
We also form communities in workshops and
with hand tools and the other kind of things
that we have at hand but one of the things
that I'm particularly interested in, and this
is kind of the heart and soul of Make, is
that instructions or patterns, patterns for
other people to follow and
sharing those instructions is pretty powerful.
Instructions are the open source of making.
It is our code
base. It's here how I did this. It might be
someone's particular way of doing it, it might
be more like a general recipe for doing a
class of things but essentially when I came
up with the idea for Make, I saw that
technology magazines really didn't contain
those kind of instructions anymore. They talked
about
technology but they didn't really say how
they were put together or how you might do
this yourself so by
having those instructions, you allow someone
to respond by saying, "I'd like to build that.
I'd like to
learn how to do that." Our very first issue
- I often use this because this was sort
of a really typical but
kind of emblematic project for Make. It was
kite aerial photography. There's a KAP community
out there and
there's all kinds of rigs you could build.
Chris Benton, who's a professor of architecture
at Berkeley,
designed one made of Popsicle sticks and using
a disposable camera, and it went off once
during a flight but
you know it was combining something that was
pretty fun anyway as a kid, to fly kites,
with photography and it really gives you a
perspective that you don't get from the ground.
This is off of Point Reyes and I don't
know, it's a little hard to see but if you
follow the black string up the kind of the
middle of it, that's kind of where the kite
is and then Chris is standing on that brown
pad in the center there taking the picture
so it began as a work project for him. As
a professor of architecture, he wanted to
see buildings from different angles and he
wanted to understand kind of how they would
like. If you look at a building straight down
from an airplane, you know you're not seeing
those angles and if you look at it from the
ground, you're only looking up so that was
his original intent but he's become actually
a photographer with a gallery of photos that
he's taken with different rigs. Take it one
step further and you began taking model rocketry
that you did as a kid and figuring out that
you could take a disposable video camera [video
playing in background] and put it inside of
the rocket and film your own space flight,
or not quite space flight, but you know what
I mean. We also see, and this is one of those
issues of making a radar detector from a Hot
Wheels toy. It's just how we're taking - in
fact, we have a lot of consumer technology
out there that people are harvesting the components
from and remaking something else with them.
One of the most popular is actually the Wii
controllers which have a lot of very cheap
sensors in them and it would be almost as
expensive to buy them separately. So again,
enthusiasts are people that are doing something
they love doing. They're playing, they are
figuring it out, and their creating a following.
In many ways, that's kind of what we do on
Twitter. We tell people about what we're doing
and share links about what other projects
are going on. We don't always do that. This
is a Tweet-a-Watt project we had where we
plug an appliance into a device called a kilowatt
and then it was modified to have a wireless
capability to upload the data to a computer
which then publishes it to Twitter so that
you could actually have a Twitter conversation
with your appliance about how much power it's
using on a daily basis. So I think when we
look out there, we see people building their
own networks around what they do. Some are
creating things, some are consuming things,
but there all sharing things back and forth
and I think it's kind of interesting. At least
as a publisher, that's how I think of my audience
as doing this stuff to extend their network
and to some degree my job is to help them
extend that network. To connect them to others
and connect them to other communities and
that's really what I see we are trying to
do at Make, is sort of creating this network
of Makers. A kind of movement where people
have used the term Maker to mean something
almost general that allows them to connect
to different groups, even though one might
be in Robotics and the other might be in soft
circuit embroidery and another might be in
fire machines. So I'm particularly interested,
and I was going to do a little more in this
talk, but it's just who's following whom in
these sort of special interest communities?
This is not necessarily Make related but this
is Twitter users most followed by people that
had posted during the Web 2 Summit, one of
our guys in research did this but I think
we're getting to a place where we're starting
to get tools through Google's open social
and others where the activity that people
are doing in these communities can be sort
of understood and connected to more easily.
I'm in the process of organizing Maker Faire
this year not just in the Bay area but in
Detroit as well as New York City, and going
to a place like Detroit is very different
then the Bay area. It's one of the most depressed
regions in the country, schools are terrible,
there's blight, there's all kinds of really
challenging issues there but there are lots
of creative and technical people there who
I think we're trying to help network them
together, to get them to know each other,
and to allow them really the freedom to work
together to create something new for Detroit.
It's pretty exciting but I think in many ways
it's like how do I - what kind of tools can
we use to make that process more transparent
to more people? Makers know where things - where
to get supplies, at least in their area. They
know where someone is an expert in something
or who makes something somewhere and I have
this idea that over time we'd like to be engaged
in mapping some of these communities in terms
of where the capabilities are, where the assets
are, where the Makers in that, and even from
a publishing point of view. Publishing talks
about, or media talks about, demographics
and psychographics. I think we're going to
come up with something close to a term like
social graphics, which allows us to understand
that each person that we talk to isn't an
individual, they're actually a network. They
take something, like a message from Twitter,
and it might be oh "Sledgehammer Fireworks.
That's a cool video. I'm going to send that
out to my group." And I'm, in a sense, feeding
my own network with content from various sources
so the idea from activity groups and other
things really connect people in terms of what
they're doing and in terms of who they are.
[inaudible] They bring together a lot of very
different styles of making. A lot of different
kinds of people and I think that makes a difference.
It's not just geeks, it's not just electronics.
There are all kinds of different kinds of
making. Some on the artistic side, some on
the deep technology side. I'm going to talk
about a few of the projects that interest
me this year that I've seen coming in for
Maker Faire. One is a Gigapan and this was
a project from Carnegie Mellon and NASA. They
collaborated on how to take high resolution
photographs like panoramas by using a device
that basically takes multiple high res photos
and then they stitch them together through
software so it's been focused on panoramas,
creating like this top image of the Bay and
the bottom image where you can zoom in but
what's kind of interesting and new that I'm
seeing is now they're starting to use for
macro photography. To take things and in effect
enlarge them the way that they've been doing
panoramas so I met with - there's a gigamacro.com;
Gene Cooper; and this a rig but what's kind
of cool in how this ties together is he's
mounted basically his camera on a CNC machine
so it can make very, very small steps to traverse
say that butterfly and take a complete picture
of it and to give you a sense of it, and this
doesn't do a great sense of it, but that's
a picture of an eagle feather that was taken
with this rig. It's composed of 7,500 different
pictures that have been stitched together,
and again, you know, you don't quite get the
idea of the resolution from my picture of
a picture but he was in the office last Friday
and it was fascinating to see what they're
doing there so again, this is, they are working
on it as a kit, as something that - and the
kind of transformation that happens is they
were talking to a natural history museum that
if someone wants to find a specimen in a natural
history museum, you have to make a reservation.
You have to fly there and look at it. What
if they create something like this that creates
a very, very high resolution image of that
object? Here's another fellow - there's a
HAM radio club. HAM is as old as, and it sort
of gives birth to electronics in many ways,
but they are connecting sensors and equipment
to measure heart rate and temperature and
communicate over frequencies but you know
also GPS so they just last weekend, or on
the 20th, did a jump from 20,000 feet to produce
that map of - here's how this jumper came
down to Earth so it's really pretty interesting.
Apart from just mapping say a
jump, they are also using it potentially to
monitor and communicate between a group of
jumpers which is
sometimes a problem in their space. I put
this in there just because - back to my copying
thing, people do
simple things that are fun. Make a photo booth
and you know the equipment is not particularly
expensive but
the idea is something that's sort of popular
and so Ray Munson building a photo booth for
Maker Faire and he wants to create photos
like that which you can go in with your girlfriend
or boyfriend and have a picture
taken. We also will have bigger things like
Soma which is the Flaming Lotus Girls installation
set up at
Maker Faire and you know, we're not just about
new technology. We also cover some of the
older stuff [video
playing in the background] This is an ad created
by one of our exhibitors [video continues
playing in
background] So the last thing I'll say, this
is a sensor activated squirrel cam so the
idea is that it's
written in a processing language on the Arduino
and outside a window is a sensor and the squirrel
trips the
sensor, takes the picture, it's uploaded to
the website, and it sends it's user an email
that the squirrel
is out there. The interesting thing is the
person that created this application said
they modified the
CatCam project in our book by Tom Igoe of
making things talk, modified it instead of
monitoring a cat, it's
monitoring a squirrel but I was looking on
the website and this is an 8th graders project
which is pretty
impressive work. So our theme for this year
at Maker Faire is Young Makers and we've been
working with Pixar and the Exploratorium to
engage more young kids in making and we had
a program last Saturday at the Exploratorium
on making music. It featured several different
kinds of people who make musical instruments
and everything from a kelp horn which is a
piece of seaweed taken from the ocean and
dried and Krys Bobrowski is a French horn
player but she plays the kelp horn and it's
beautiful sound. Through Walter
Kitundu, who started off as a DJ, and he began
obviously making sounds with a turntable then
began adding
other things and ways of making sound next
to the turntable and began making instruments
and he demonstrated a kind of harp that was
also connected to his computer and he was
looping out some beautiful sounds, and then
Gee Wang from Stanford who is the developer
of the Ocarina application, which is, you
know, you blow into the IPhone and you play
it like a flute, so there's such an interesting
mix of technologies here but part of it is
we want to open it up to - we are seeing it
open up to kids more and more, to get kids
making things. It's a great way for them to
take something in the magazine and copy it
and try to make it
themselves. Our next issue, which comes out
in a couple of weeks, is called "Remote Control
Everything" and it actually started because
I found some guy's; we didn't replicate this
in the magazine but they modified a car so
they could drive it with an IPhone. I mean,
sit on the roof of the car and you know, go
left, right,
forward, backward. It's on a test track as
we say but it's pretty interesting. This one,
you can't see it very well, but it's a lawnmower
so you can sit in your chair, have your drink,
and let the robotic lawnmower
mow your lawn and that's the kind of things
that's coming up. You also see up there "Build
this Twittering
Cat Toy" so we are still back to cats and
we're still back to pets. Ways to every time
your cat hits the toy, it sends a message
to you and let you know that the cat is active
somehow. That's pretty much what I wanted
to kind of show you is just sort of some different
kinds of projects, different kinds of patterns
of making that I'm seeing and we'd love to
have you. Maker Faire is also - our applications
are still open. If you have a garage project
or something that you're working on, something
you'd like to share with other people; anything
from a performance piece, an installation
piece, an exhibit, a tabletop full of electronics
and explain to people, we'd love to have you
there. If you go to makerfaire.com, there's
the call for
Makers link, and fill it out and let us know
what you'd like to do there. So, thank you
very much and I'd be
happy to answer any questions you have. [applause]